after he was sworn in as governor
governor younkin began implementing his
campaign promises and for the simple act
of fulfilling his popular proposals that
got him elected in a purple to blue
state that is virginia many on the left
are vilifying yunkan now the washington
post you can check it almost every day
they smear him now nearly on a daily
basis for no logical reason except they
hate anybody that's conservative jim
acosta quivered as he announced that
glenn younkin was turning virginia into
a soviet style police state
by making masks
optional
liberal school boards in northern
virginia defied younkin's executive
order on masks spending massless sending
massless students apparently home and
you know trying to stick it to the new
republican governor now these democrats
are playing political football but the
people they're playing football with are
your kids
thankfully they're losing the virginia
senate by the way controlled by
democrats they just voted to end the
mass mandates in schools by a whopping
margin of 29 to nine as younkin stated
quote this vote shows that school boards
are attacking their own students they're
suddenly detached from stunningly
detached from reality and it's time to
put kids first and get back to normal
joining us now with more is the virginia
governor glenn younkin
i think your win is a preview of coming
attractions you made a campaign promise
the issue of children's schools was a
huge issue in your campaign
you kept your promise
then then school districts decided not
to listen to you and now
apparently got democrats in the
legislature going along with you
yeah sean this is a defining moment for
parents and kids in virginia and we have
a bipartisan movement to get parents
back in charge of their kids lives
because remember parents matter and
that's what voters said loudly in
november and so all of a sudden now
where virginia has been leading we're
seeing the rest of the country also come
around us
because it's time to get back to normal
it's time to empower parents and i am so
excited that virginia is leading in a
bipartisan way to give parents the the
power to choose whether their child
wears a mask or not in school
all right the question is you're given
the option if parents want their kids to
still wear the mask the parents can
instruct their kids to wear the mask
then it's their choice
um i thought democrats were pro-choice
well this is this is the reality of i
think the the the misperceptions that
the media is trying to drive if you want
to wear a mask wear a mask
and as if you don't want your child to
wear a mask then they shouldn't wear a
mask and this is a decision that parents
should make we've been talking about
this for a year in virginia this is one
of the major factors that led to our win
in november we went to work on day one
driving forward our agenda 11 executive
actions 59 bills in our house and our
senate 25 budget amendments to put our
day one game plan to work and part of
that is empowering parents and i am so
excited to see a bipartisan group come
together
and recognize that virginia voters are
the ones we all work for not the
education unions or the school boards we
work for parents and kids and teachers
and we're going to allow parents to make
a decision for their kids you know in
virginia we're going to get taxes down
we're going to make our schools great
again we in fact are going to make our
communities safe we're going to get our
economy moving again in order to create
jobs for everybody and guess what we're
going to stand up for our constitutional
rights these are not republican values
these are virginia values these are
american values and i'm so excited to
see our senate work on a bipartisan
basis to deliver part of the agenda
you know i want to read to a tweet he's
not the brightest
knife in the drawer but to be honest joe
lockhart the former press secretary he
tweeted what does he do first talking
about you he encourages kids to go to
school without a mask kids will die
the same old republicans and others
called you even worse names
what's interesting to me now is
now you've got a new jersey governor
nearly lost if we would have paid a
little more attention i think that
governorship could have been won by
republicans
then you've got delaware now you've got
the beginning of ending the mass
mandates in new york they haven't done
it for kids yet but i think it will soon
follow
now all those very same people are quiet
and i have noticed a pattern that it
seems the washington post has a hit
piece on you every single day and if
they get it wrong i hope you sue them
well sean when you're making change
there are people that are going to
disagree with you as i said virginians
sent us here to do a job and i'm going
to do it and i'm not going to make
everybody happy along the way but you
know what in in the campaign folks
actually said that we weren't going to
deliver and we've delivered and we in
fact are pressing forward and and i know
that that those people that disagree
with me are going to continue to do
everything they can to stop us but you
know what virginians sent us here to get
something done we are going to deliver
this as i said is a absolute big moment
for virginia's families for virginia
parents for virginia kids and i can't
wait to go to work tomorrow to get the
next thing done